all right let's see about getting this
whole thing going ere we go that's what
I'm after yes yes cool am i coming
through all right that's question number
one
oh good looks like it hey from Scotland
Oh welcome it's about midnight where you
are so hope you don't have work in the
morning um yeah I'm you guys are
honestly really lucky that I'm not just
in pajamas right now I managed to catch
a stomach bug or I either caught a
stomach bug or the or the Chinese food I
had last night was not good I don't know
which was the case but had a rough
morning definitely not 100% yet but
definitely better than I was so I didn't
want to miss you folks let's see oh the
Hufflepuff from Reno a little out of
focus yeah I mean I don't know how much
I can do about that with the because I'm
still doing this off the phone yeah I'm
not gonna be my sharpest today hey folks
I hope you're okay with that appreciate
this shirt oh yeah I love this shirt uh
my mother got me this shirt for
Christmas uh oh jeez sorry Meg sounds
like you uh you had it rough - oh it's
11 p.m. in Ireland I forget that the UK
is big enough to have more than one
timezone okay so I do have a few thing
this is not gonna be as uh as organized
as
I sometimes am but I do have a few
things to bring up touch on love your
channel I've been a fan for for a year
ish now worth staying up oh thank you
very much
yeah no no don't don't worry I'm not
planning to I'm not playing to what
might and push myself enough I feel like
I got a duck out early I'm prepared to
do that I think I'll be okay though
so I suppose the the big thing that's
worth talking about full trailer for
Aladdin came out and it was um it was
really frustrating for me because
watching that trailer
I saw glimpses of the movie I actually
would have gone to see which would have
been a straightforward non-musical you
know appropriately cast version of this
story I honestly would have been
completely on board for that but the
fact that they're recycling the songs is
means it falls into the same category as
the vast majority of the other Disney
live-action or photorealistic in the
case of the Lion King reboot things
which is they're just it's literally
it's just recycling it's not going back
to the story and doing a new take which
I wouldn't have a problem with that I
don't have a problem with them going
back to the source material there's a
ton of ways to do those stories but the
fact that these are so blatantly just
treading on the nostalgia just ticks me
off
um I will say it's good that Will Smith
is not going to be blue the entire thing
he looked way better
well he wasn't colored blue other than
that
I'm still really underwhelmed by the
Jafar that they've got he doesn't have a
lot of presents to him which I guess
they're going for the more sort of
realistic scheming Vizier but that's way
less interesting as far as I'm concerned
and and like so like there's
bit of Aladdin fleeing from the guards
and I'm watching that thinking that
looks like a movie I'd actually like to
see as he's like parkouring his way
through the streets to get away from
these guys I'm like like these as
glimpses of
if that was the movie I had actually not
only not have a problem with it I might
even go see it but you know then they
started singing friend like me including
some of the very specific imagery from
the animated version which immediately
made me just the entire premise of the
thing Snoop Dogg should have been the
evil guy from Aladdin uh that would have
been interesting I'll give you that
genie looked better yeah even when he
was blue he did look better than he did
on that first reveal uh
look of him but I still think he looked
better when he wasn't blue like
substantially better and I and like the
little bits of rapport that we get
between Genie and Aladdin I liked that
so like the stuff that did not
immediately make me go I know exactly
what that shot slipped it from there's
that song the parts that didn't the
parts that did not go out of their way
to remind me about the animated version
I was kind of like oh but have you seen
the Doctor Who documentary a journey in
space and time um I've seen an adventure
in space in time which was sort of the
docudrama I don't think I've seen a
straight documentary on it you have the
same screwdrivers but I've got I've got
all those screwdrivers so far as I'm
aware at least without getting into like
custom stuff off Etsy for way too much
money it looks the only one I might
consider watching the Lion King is for
John Oliver he looks like a British
parrot yeah I mean casting was solved
for that I there's no way I like that
that one more than any other and like
these have all ticked me off but that
honestly more than any other really
ticks me off
cuz it's still animation so what okay I
don't need to not get that worked up
is anyone else finding aware that
there's a left side to the studio studio
boy haha how cool would it be if this
room could qualify as a studio its water
I'm hydrating water in quotes believe
whatever you wanna believe what else
went on um oh if anyone um didn't see it
already Kevin Smith put out a really
sweet video talking about Stan Lee's
cameo in in Captain Marvel and if you've
seen Captain Marvel already definitely
check it out if you don't think you're
gonna see Captain Marvel it's a story
worth worth saying hmmm tell and you
know if if you don't mind minor spoilers
cuz it did that came in have it's not
too far another thing Thank You Connor
there's this OVA from 1987 called robot
carnival it's so phenomenal that I can
call my favorite anime of all time have
you ever heard of it no actually like
the thing with anime I I don't watch a
ton of anime but I've heard of a fair
amount that one I have not heard of so
that one's new to me oh it's just in
your vids the studio seems to it seems
to end with the shelves I mean like
that's the idea I I frame it
normal shot to cut off at the shelves so
that you know you can imagine it just it
just keeps going but you know there's a
wall right there and that does that's
and go that much farther if you went to
comic-con what doctor would you dress up
it well like as of right now it will
probably be thirteen because that's the
most complete cosplay out that I have I
have kind of a makeshift eleven and so
like just by default I'd probably go
thirteen cuz I've got basically that
complete outfit whereas other ones I
just kind of have bits and pieces and
don't have with a full look going on
love your doctor who reviews thank you
very much
oh actually okay since Comic Cons got
mentioned I I haven't like booked my
ticket to this yet so it's not
absolutely 100% but I'm pretty sure I
figured out which con I'm going to this
year since Vermont comic-con isn't
happening and thanks to patreon support
I can actually afford to travel for one
con I can't afford to go to more than
one this year but it's I'm probably
gonna end up going to terrific on in
Connecticut is the one that lined up the
best with my schedule and and and looked
pretty decent from what I could see it
was between that and Heroes con but then
things with my schedule kind of made
heroes con a little bit like I'm not so
sure this kind of works and that's most
likely what its gonna be and that is in
August
um I do not remember the exact dates off
the top of my head but that's probably
gonna be the one I go to by the way good
hair thank you I I like I'm so over dude
to get this recolor but I don't have the
time I would love to see schalke doctor
cosplay I mean that would be cool just
as a deep cut like to see how many
people even like figure out what it is
you're doing I think I'm like that's the
to cosplay that like they that'd be good
to take to something like Gallifrey 1
I'm not sure that like a normal
comic-con I I mean just speaking
personally I know I get bummed out if I
want the whole con and nobody knew what
I was doing what are the odds that I'm
also sick at home I'm not sure
statistically but I hope you recover
soon I am I'll see how I am in the
morning I should be back at work what do
you think of scream with a shotgun
I need to I need to watch it again I
haven't watched that in WoW um jeez
maybe yes it's definitely been more than
that it's been a long time since I've
seen that so I really do need to just
watch it again
front to back
if you hadn't heard of it I cannot
recommend it enough it's one of my
favorite works of animation period I
will I will try to look into it the Mott
my to-do list is daunting
speaking of which I got a few more
episodes into the Umbrella Academy I
think I've I've now done the first four
episodes of that show and I am actually
quite enjoying it funny thing that it
kind of made me realize well um I had
suspected this but it kind of confirmed
it for me which is that I've long
suspected that I would like darker you
know more violence kind of swearing a
little bit you know slightly twisted
being a superhero isn't that great kind
of stories if they were told with
original characters as opposed to using
existing characters who weren't built to
function like that and telling those
kinds of stories with them
identity crisis um and watching Umbrella
Academy kind of confirm that for me it's
like I'm really enjoying this but I did
I think it was after the second episode
I kind of paused and thought you know if
this was like some sort of weird version
of I don't know the powerpack or
something I'd probably hate it so you
know it
it's almost like you can't just slap
dark and gritty onto just any property
and have it work
it's weird I know let's see Thank You
Meg I would legit pay for drunk review
and reaction videos also any plans to oh
dang it
I lost it also any plans to read I of
the hair anytime soon if so what colors
um hopefully soon I haven't made it I
haven't scheduled it cuz I'm um
winter in Vermont the heating bills
gotta kick your butt
so um kind of the way you have to do it
is to save up across the summer so that
you don't get into too bad a hole by the
time you're done with winter and so I'm
in the process of trying to get out of
the the winter heating bill hole once
I'm out of that maybe I'll address the
hair I'm I'm probably gonna do the
colors I did before again maybe add an
additional color into it but knowing how
long it'll probably be before I'm able
to refresh it or get it redone what I
like about these codes is they have
continued to look nice as they've faded
so that kind of puts them top of my
lists and I have a lot of other friends
who dyed their hair so I kinda have a
frame of reference for what like green
or orange or you know really red red you
know kind of looks like when it fades
and I'm looking at that going look it
can look good but you've got to be
prepared to refresh that more frequently
than I'm gonna be able to do she'll miss
your little stuffed puppy that's next to
the cards against humanity' that my
friend that is ein and if you've ever
seen Cowboy Bebop you know who this
little guy is this was sent from a
friend of mine a podcasting friend by
the name of Jean Hendricks once he found
out that I was doing the the podcast
revisit on
on Cowboy Bebop have you ever been to a
Star Wars Celebration I have not and
honestly like that might be too big for
me like I'm I'm probably never gonna go
to the San Diego Comic Con or probably
not even really the New York one they
just feel they're just too much like
that
Boston was overwhelming for me at times
so yeah I something like Star Wars
Celebration I think it's just it's just
too much what are the best and worst
aspects of Moffitt's writing um they are
in fact the same thing he he he swung
big which meant that he that his
tendency to do that meant he both hit
home runs and struck out so times I do
the exact same thing which side of
modern who do you prefer seers one
through five or series six through 11
it's hard to say because like I am in
the middle of a revisit on the earlier
stuff I don't so I I don't know I don't
really feel comfortable saying that oh
oh alright that's a mean question
hell-bent or the Dexter finale mm-hmm
okay so if you were gonna make me say
which of those is worse the Dexter
finale is worse because that was it in
the show literally could not recover
after that cuz it was over as much as I
hate hell-bent I also love series 10 so
hell-bent is an episode I can't stand
but like it didn't wreck the show the
Dexter finale is so bad I couldn't go
back and watch the good seasons of
Dexter I tried rewatching season 2 which
is my favorite season of Dexter and I
couldn't enjoy it cuz in the back of my
head there was a little voice going none
of this matters cuz it still ends in
that completely atrocious ending I just
I can't enjoy the show any more I used
to love it so that that will always be
the
the worse not gonna lie that's a nice
shirt yeah I do I do enjoy this shirt
see I was reminded of green okay that's
that's an internal conversation how long
does it take you to edit each video on
average um depends it's getting longer
because I'm some of the stuff that I've
got working that I'm doing now is a
little bit more involved editing time is
actually pretty short though
traditionally up to this point because I
you know when I ramble in my reviews I'm
unscripted but I've been doing it long
enough that I can hit my points and wrap
it up and I don't have to pause and
collect my thoughts and I usually don't
go on divergences that don't go anywhere
so it's usually just a matter of you
know putting on the beginning and the
ending and turning cutting out me
turning the camera on and then turning
the camera off that's usually about it
and even with the scripted stuff
actually ie
it's weird I am much better reading the
text going on a teleprompter than like
having a page in front of me which is
kind of weird but I actually can can do
a single take on even a scripted video
which is weird I had any I hadn't
expected that to be the case
Dexter finale of lost finale I didn't
watch more than the first season a loss
so I couldn't tell you can you review
the alien movies
see that that just that just feels like
a chore because I refuse to see that
last one and there's really only two of
them that are good and then one that's
almost good and then one that fails in
kind of a fascinating way and then it's
just pain after that I got
I kind of miss being able to now you
about passion of the nerd ah
not only have I subscribed to that
channel but I'd caught up on all of his
videos ha or at least all the Buffy ones
which is the main thing that he does I
was a pre-emptive pop what are your
thoughts on us awesome makes volume 1 &
2 from both guardians of the galaxy
films I don't know cuz I didn't buy them
cuz most of the songs from those
soundtracks that I like I already owned
so I didn't buy them I couldn't tell you
you're real you're really cute not
looking too bad for having thrown up
about 12 hours ago
yeah I'm Tibet any chance of council
geek Brandon wineglasses with quote it's
water or a quote I'm rehydrating ah I
don't know I have expanded the merch a
little bit I didn't do an announcement
on unlike the community feed of the
YouTube channel but if you follow me on
Facebook I did I did put it up there I
did a I did a shirt of the nerd is
constant the gender is fluid so I am
trying to get additional merch things
going but because of me and Technology
like trying to actually make a
storefront for it I'm finding
frustrating because things never work
for me the way that they're supposed to
have you seen the American Pie film
series I have seen the first three I
didn't see American Reunion um they're
products of their time I mean as far as
those things go it's I mean they're
problematic is tight but pretty much any
teenage comedy ten years on from when
they make it is gonna be problematic as
heck that's kind of the nature of the
genre so I mean like they're fine I
didn't I didn't love them like the the
first one came out and was like a
weirdly like big deal and I couldn't
figure out why especially because I'd
seen clerks which is way dirtier I mean
not visually but in terms of concepts
and what's talked about so like I wasn't
that bowled over by uh by American Pie
any thoughts on the Cushing doctor if I
ever get around to seeing those I will
let you know um and I say that and I
will get around to seeing them
eventually I have no idea when what
video did you originally say Fu Moffitt
in so I can watch it that was my 10
worst Doctor Who episodes written by
Steven Moffat video so find that one
that's that's where that clip came from
do you watch mr. TARDIS reviews if so
thoughts um
intermittently I'm not habitually I've
been like binge do stuff so I don't I
mean like I liked what I saw but I
haven't gone through everything
what else did I have that like went on
or was announced um
Oh Marvel is apparently thinking about
doing a what-if series for the Disney
Plus streaming app which honestly I'm on
I'm on board with that in theory my only
concern about it is what's always nice
about the Marvel what-if stories because
they're like alternate takes on you know
what if this played out differently how
would the world be different what would
happen to the heroes nine times out of
ten they're really depressing and sad um
but sort of the fun of them is just
seeing how badly things go and I do
worry on a streaming budget that they're
not going to be able to go as big as I
like what if stories to go but
conceptually I'm down with that idea I
think that's that's a solid concept for
them to build a build a show around so
what else did I have oh gosh
apparently AMC is planning an orphan
black universe series like a new series
set in the world of orphan black
but orphan black was a show that when it
worked it worked fairly well but like
the world was actually not very
interesting and was often incoherent and
the best stuff was the acting in the
characters so the idea of giving me more
in that world without those characters I
could not possibly care less for the
record I bailed on orphan black I don't
know four episodes are so into season
four when I realized they have no plan
on I'm making this up as they go which I
don't have an inherent problem with but
like the show had been framed as if they
were planning to go somewhere and it was
really clear they didn't know what they
were doing Thank You Tracy good to see
you
which would you rather be killed by you
can't say I would rather not die Dalek
Cyberman weeping angels silence
sontarans slitheen or Vashta Nerada um
my inclination would be either the
weeping angels or the Vashta Nerada
depending on whether or not the the
angels are killing me with the zap me
back in time or the neck brain the neck
break I'm a little more iffy on if I
don't get to pick and it can go either
way I'll take the Vashta Nerada that
seemed really quick and the thing is
most of the other ones Daleks Cybermen
silence all the others when
when people get hit with what what those
villains used to kill you know they're
always going so obviously it hurts it's
not instantaneous so I'll I'll take the
bastion Narada also because the thing
about the bastion of Narada is I not
only would it be quick I probably
wouldn't even see it coming so I
wouldn't even have the fear issue going
on
hugh jackman is to play Harold Hill the
new Broadway mute and the new Broadway
production of The Music Man I don't
remember the music man very well I've
seen it as a play once before I mean
that like he's good for the
song-and-dance stuff he'll be good in it
Wonder Woman was the best DC movie do
you agree or disagree I'm I'm assuming
you're limiting that to the current DC
Cinematic Universe as opposed to any DC
movie which would obviously bring in
things like The Dark Knight and the 89
Batman and the original Superman movie
so I'm assuming you're not counting any
of those and just doing the continuity
that started with the Man of Steel and
within those parameters yes I do think
Wonder Woman is probably the best one
Aquaman was pretty good both have their
issues Wonder Woman's third act is is
not great and Aquaman is honestly kind
of all over the place but it is really
fun as it does that so they're they're
not massively far apart is what I would
say have you watched penny dreadful I
did the first episode of Penny dreadful
and it was okay for some reason it
didn't hook me enough to come back to it
evening from the Hufflepuff in Scotland
you're early
well I'm early cuz I know I said um last
week that tonight was gonna be a 9 p.m.
but that's because I'm a [ __ ] who got
my schedule all mixed up and it's
another week that's gonna be thrown off
with the timing it's not this week so
there you go
thoughts on Mark Gatiss is Doctor Who
stories I don't like most of his uh his
stories I mean I think he didn't robots
of Sherwood right I think that's the one
he did that I liked the best uh I just
saw Aquaman a couple weeks ago lots of
fun yeah it was it was is the buy rent
video coming in April perhaps um
hopefully it is my hope to get the
bisexual representation video out in
April the hitch is is that's one that
I'm having someone else come on with me
and we haven't gotten the schedules
lined up yet and I haven't filmed it yet
so that still has to fall into place
that is my plan that is my hope but I'm
not gonna promise you that right now
because it depends on how everything
kind of goes in the next month or so how
did you get that thirteenth doctor door
that was sent to me which actually I'm
gonna forget if I don't do it now so um
I've mentioned at the end of most of the
videos this month that it is my birthday
this month it's 21st for the record for
those wondering and um I have started
getting stuff showing up either in the
PIO box or actually at my door if it
came off the Amazon wish list now I I
feel bad because it didn't occur to me
until a bit later that I really should
have been like setting aside everything
that it was getting so I could share all
of it and give thanks for all of it but
the problem was like a lot of it I
started putting away to where it would
go and I'm not sure I remembered like
gathering up everything so if you've
sent me something and I've gotten it and
I don't mention it I'm sorry and I
apologize in advance but the stuff that
that I've got in front of me here that
has been sent to me for birthday related
actually first of all the earrings see
if this shows up decently at all so
little studs with transgender symbol
to quite enjoy um God movement so I get
sent um a couple of blu-rays Doctor Who
ninth series now obviously I've seen
series nine before but the thing is I am
big on physical media like not so big
that I'm like a hoarder I don't have a
massive massive collection but like if I
really like something and while I have
mixed feelings about Series nine I do
want to be complete on New Era who I
want to be sure I have it on physical
medium because I don't trust digital
only I just don't I I don't like the
fact that it is within the power of the
rights holders to decide that I can't
have anymore and to just take it from me
because technically when you buy digital
you are leasing and I don't like that um
Oh Meg thank you again I just want to
say that I love your videos is a huge
help for me when I feel the worst to
just sit down and binge your videos
thank you for every bit thank you wow
thank you so much well okay so I got
Constantine city of demons which is
awesome and I love it this made my top
ten movies of 2018 and I haven't read
this yet because I'm in a slightly weird
place on it so volume 2 of rat Queens
which I do want to read but
unfortunately I now have the burden of
knowledge because I found out about the
domestic violence charges against the
artists rock up Church now he was when
that happened he was removed from the
book but it's it's either the first two
or three I think it's only the first two
but definitely this volume still has his
art which you know makes me feel a
little I mean I'll still read it but you
know I'm really looking forward to
getting through to the point that I will
you know be reading stuff that wasn't
drawn by him I'll appreciate that but I
am still very glad to have this cuz the
first volume you know setting that issue
aside which I didn't find about and find
out about until
try reading this volume is business
series drag queens the first volume was
great so I am looking forward to this
when I am feeling up or you know the
headspace of it blu-rays forever yeah
yeah I I do agree with that what kind of
music do you like
boy I could ask that one a fair amount
umm really all over the place it's it I
don't know I was I was like I was raised
on 70s rock so it was raised on like The
Beatles and The Rolling Stones and James
Taylor at this point like if I were to
think of who I have the most albums of
it would be people like pink Lindsey
Stirling miracle of sound I had one that
I just lost but you know even there
there are other ones that I like a lot
that maybe I only have one or two you
know albums from you know like Fleetwood
Mac rumours I love that album I don't
own other Fleetwood Mac stuff I also
have a fair amount of soundtracks both
movie and video games from my era of
video games meaning you know like 90s
and and mostly 90s I'm all about hard
copies of media - oh good I'm not the
only one where do I find this Merlin
miniseries uh if you mean the two-part
mini I actually don't know how hard that
is to find I remember when that aired
actually like that pretty well excited
to react to your gridlock review oh I
hope you enjoy it that one has been shot
I need to shoot the next few thank you
for ringing new and old doctor poo to
all audiences I love classic who I have
a blog but you are an inspiration
Oh
folks are too nice you really are
thoughts I'm Breaking Bad was good I
enjoyed it was solid was it built well
was a good piece of work how do i
cheaply watch classic Doctor Who brick
box that's how I watch it it's it's a
it's a subscription streaming service
but it's fairly affordable and if you're
in a country that you can actually get
brick box then it gives you access to
almost everything even steak you look
good please do repo full review much
love um
repo is on my list of things to do a why
it's awesome video about so that is on
that is on my list whiner cider its
water the the bottle is red but it is
water I always look forward to your
monthly LGBT content love the passion
yeah I'm really glad that that all that
has gone over well enough that you know
that I that I still feel comfortable
doing it I got nervous when I started
doing that stuff but it's gone really
well okay I do have some others oh the
Disney Fox Deal is finally going to
close God we've been dealing with this
thing forever
um actually day before my birthday is
supposed to close on the 20th okay
here's a weird one and somebody may have
to fill me in on something here so
apparently Capcom is working with
Netflix on a Dragon's Dogma animated
series which one presumes is taking
inspiration from the Castlevania
animated series except that like the
Dragon's Dogma have more than one game I
was pretty sure was just the one and I
didn't think it made that big of a
splash so like I don't
and that seems like an odd pick
especially coming from Capcom cuz like
if I were gonna say hey what Capcom
property would make a good animated
series my immediate thought is double my
Devil May Cry which is now in the public
consciousness cuz it just had a new game
come out so yeah Dragon's Dogma I don't
know why that said I am glad that more
people are gonna try the streaming
series version of adapting video game
stuff because at least so far it's
working a heck of a lot better than the
movies have been so yeah we'll see oh
wow somebody will see I suspect unless a
trailer really blows me away I'll
probably skip that one I never play
Dragon's Dogma favorite Doctor Who
quotes my favorite Doctor Who quote is
from a Big Finish
story called the Holy Terror and it is
it doesn't matter to to whom the cruelty
is directed the cruelty itself is wrong
I love that as a line I love that as a
sentiment I try and keep that one in my
head that's yeah Devil May Cry already
had an anime out and it's great how long
ago was that though I feel like that was
a while ago like long enough that like
statute of limitations would be up to to
do another crack at it I never saw that
so I'll take your word on how how good
it was do you think it's sad we didn't
get more time with Eccleston yeah yeah I
mean I like the way he was playing the
doctor in an odd way kind of works for
only one series you know that he is as
broken by the time war as he is that it
kind of makes sense that he he kind of
needed to refresh so that it does work
for me but you know the fact that he
hasn't hasn't done Big Finish hasn't
come back I would like him to I know
there's like weird behind the scenes
politics that we only kind of have a
partial picture of so I don't hold my
breath for it
if you don't use 30 second plus clips of
one clip or more than ten minutes total
YouTube usually won't claim you I only
got one claim and they demonetised well
not see that's AG that's not true it all
has to do with who has the copyright on
the clip you're using that determines
everything because there are some
studios some companies that are jerks
and there's some that aren't and it
doesn't have anything to do with how
long the clip is now having a shorter
clip makes a fair use argument easier to
defend but that is not a guarantee that
you won't get a claim Paramount has
claimed my videos because of a still
image up for ten seconds so it it has to
do with who the copyright holder is
paramount are jerks
Fox while not total jerks they are one
of the ones that that I got demonetized
on like back when I kind of experimented
with doing the the trailer reactions
like where you'd have the trailer down
in the corner of the video I don't do
that anymore but Fox claimed on me
Disney didn't because I did one on Star
Wars the last Jedi so that they didn't
claim me but paramount did Fox has given
me some trouble the BBC is giving me
grief right now so it there is nothing
that you can do that guarantees you
don't get flagged if you are using a
clip you can get flagged depending on
who owns it you may not depending on how
you are using it you may win it on
appeal but you know jerk companies are
jerk companies Dragon's Dogma is an 8
out of 10
isn't that like the baseline for video
games is that like a see these days I
feel like a lot of the video game review
especially like the the big sites they
almost
a seven from them is like oh god that's
not good so I don't know how to take
that do you know if brick boxes in
Australia I do not know I know it's not
in Britain are weirdly enough I guess
it's because they have iPlayer in
Britain and they want you to use that
although I don't know if classic who's
on that but brick box is not in the UK I
don't know if it's in Australia or not I
couldn't tell you
YouTube doesn't claim it's the right
host yeah that was also part of my point
YouTube itself is not making claims on
anything now YouTube has its own BOTS to
try in and catch the most egregious
stuff like just flat-out uploading a
episode of something or whatever but the
ones who actually place a claim are the
copyright holders who have their own
BOTS thoughts on Shazam it looks fun
that that new trailer that hit and look
I like that they're leaning into the fun
and the light and the family-friendly I
don't have a lot of investment in that
character it doesn't make me personally
really excited to see the movie but I'm
glad that it exists and I'm glad that DC
is it's giving a crack at you know
remembering superheroes could be for
kids ah
so I'm really glad that it looks like
it's it's going all in on that element
but again it doesn't necessarily make me
personally want to watch it all that
much it's one of those things that it
depends on what my life is like if it if
I have to like move my schedule around
or it's a pain in the butt for me to try
and get to the theater that's the kind
of thing I might skip we'll see though I
have asked this so much but I'm kind of
desperate for an answer sorry if this
sounds needy but will you ever talk
react to BBC's Merlin I really enjoy it
I haven't seen any episodes of that and
it's that is not on my to-do list
largely because of its age so and that's
not to say I'll never watch it but I'm
saying unless I felt the unless I did
watch it which again I don't know when
time but unless I washed it like really
felt boy I really need to do a deep dive
and analysis of this it's unlikely that
I would do a review on it even if I saw
it just because of how of how old it is
unless I'm let again unless I really
felt like I had something to say so I I
hate giving an answer I don't hold your
breath but that's kind of what it would
be for that
what were the five episodes in series
eight you thought were Matt oh boy see
if I can remember now because then like
that that video was scripted so I had
that written out and like I knew it was
five because I'd like I looked at the
episode list for series 8 off the top of
my head
honestly what I remember I thought deep
breath was man um god I'm trying to even
remember since series 8 now this stuff
doesn't stick in my head um like these
kind of details all that well okay you
know what this is gonna bug me give me a
second let me get a list um and in the
meantime what can I talk about ah
ah come on give me a break here yeah no
I know I did that this darn thing isn't
updating for me which is irritating um
well shoot okay and now you get to hear
me fumbling around on the computer which
is the most compelling possible way to
livestream I'm sure you're all
enthralled episode lists here we go
okay so series eight the ones that I
thought were just kind of met in other
words ones that I didn't think were
great but I didn't think we're actually
bad for series 8 that was deep breath
time heist the caretaker
listen sorry and into the Dalek so those
were the five that I was just kind of
met on at least I think those were the
five I was thinking of like again I
didn't I didn't like other than like
check my math when I when I scripted
that I didn't I didn't I didn't to
carefully examine that heaven-sent or
Dalek heaven-sent that's that I had that
would still be my preference your 6x me
and hope you feel better well I'm better
than I was this morning was bad this
morning was very bad I'm not a hundred
percent my stomach still a little bit
but like not blue just yeah how
how's that for medically specific
information time Heidi's and listen
better put the quantum down girl there
right look I like to listen a lot when I
watched it the first time it has gone
down in my estimation over time and time
heist was fine there's nothing wrong the
time heist I just don't think it's great
um can we see your peaked cap oh god I
have to get over there ah sure what that
give me one second oh yeah enjoy the
show
ah
so yeah thrilling I know I'm not gonna
put it on because like I took a shower
just before starting this so my hair's
wet and I'd prefer not to have hat hair
when I wake up in the morning if I can
help it why drink water out of a wine
bottle because it holds a heck of a lot
more water than just a cup or a glass so
like I am where I am shooting this is
not immediately accessible to drinkable
water I would have to go all the way
downstairs so this is just like this is
what I used at home instead of like a
refillable plastic bottle or whatever so
that's why I like the bonds it's a cool
bottle I like it would you ever consider
reading Homestuck I don't know enough
about it I do know that it's like super
dense so probably not what episode
actually terrified you I mean proper
scare um honestly the empty childhood
really did freak me out the like
initially the way it's filmed
conceptually I found the empty child to
be pretty scary you know what also
occurred to me when I got him to get the
Hat you can see my my pajama pants so
you're welcome I don't know um what's
your favorite Doctor Who fan art I don't
um I don't indulge in a ton of fan art
like I I see it every now and then I
usually like it but I don't like know
the artists and or things like that so I
I couldn't tell you sounds like you
could do with a mini-fridge I don't have
space in here for a mini-fridge are you
in an attic are there ghosts um no and
yes I used to shoot in the attic if you
go back to not all of them but some of
the later green-screen ones those were
actually shot in the Attic which is
why the sound is so terrible on them
because the acoustics of their socked
that was the reason I stopped shooting
up there though the reason I stopped
shooting up there is because I we get
cluster flies up there and if you're not
in New England you might not know where
they are but they're just these big fat
black house fly is they don't bite or
anything but they are super loud oh god
I couldn't deal with them anymore so
that that's why I started the the set up
down here
have you read lock and key I have not
Buffy or Angel depends on what aspect I
thought angel ended better and like had
a stronger overall trajectory as a show
whereas Buffy was a little bit more up
and down as it went along so like I
could I could answer either one but for
different reasons what would be the
worst doctor outfit combination I think
Eccleston would look horrible in Jodie's
outfit I think yeah anybody and Colin
Baker's outfit including Colin Baker I
don't know how you can realistically
make an argument frame although honestly
a Joe Tehan Triton's outfit that that
would be that'd be rough will you ever
read Doctor Who fan fiction or write
some probably not and definitely not
fanfiction has never really been my bag
because I'm I'm a nitpicker and like I
remember trying to read fanfiction like
in college and getting really ticked off
whenever a detail was wrong like like
sometimes big stuff sometimes just tiny
things like no no so like I couldn't
enjoy reading them and I definitely
won't write it because I I would like to
spend my time when I write to write
something that I could feasibly like
publish for sale you know I I know you
can publish fanfiction on like there
there are websites for that or whatnot
but like I it's part of my
maybe possibly we'll see if that ever
comes together a long-term plan to try
and not have to keep a full-time day job
would include getting more written works
out there cuz like that cuz I got the
book out and it's not it wasn't a huge
seller or anything but it has been a
steady drip feed of income and it's the
kind of thing where I look at and go you
know if I had four or five pieces out
there bringing in money at the rate
roughly that the book is that would be
that would be a decent chunk of change
so what's your opinion on forests of the
night it's not good it doesn't work it's
not nearly as bad as other people like
people put it like in worst list I don't
find in force than I offensively bad but
it is bad I just kind of doesn't work I
thought Jodi looked good and Capaldi's
outfit actually she did for that brief
period she had it what would you do to
improve the new Doctor Who series uh I
mean they need to find a reason for
these companions to be traveling with a
doctor because as I mentioned in my
series of live in video I don't know why
they're traveling with her and I don't
know why she wants them there aside from
just this general you know ho-oh
fam thing is like yeah but why like
these just these were just the people
you happen to you know run into wait
right after you regenerated like I can't
find a better reason for them to still
be latched together which I mean I
suppose on the one sense I kind of
appreciate because it means
theoretically we'll see if it happens
this way that theoretically any of the
convenience could leave the TARDIS
without having to die or be lost in time
or whatever else so I guess you know
making them not so attached to the
doctor means it's easier to remove them
without doing something traumatic but at
the same time it does make me go like
why why are you guys together I don't
know
why that that's kind of my big thing if
you redid your ten worst new who
episodes do you think the runaway bride
would land on there probably not I mean
I'd have to think about that but I don't
think so because Ronald why don't wanna
wave why'd runaway bride is not a very
good episode at all and it's a
frustrating one for me too to revisit
what I did but it doesn't it just kind
of tires me it doesn't quite get me
angry thoughts on venom it was fun
hopefully the sequel gives them actually
a decent story oh like ah let's see what
do you prefer Buffy the Vampire Slayer
or Xena Warrior Princess I never watched
a Xena actually I think that like saw
randomly one or two episodes I do like
Lucy Lawless she's a very cool person
and again has a great presence but I
never got into Xena what would you like
to see in Wonder Woman 1984 I would like
to not be annoyed by Kristen Wiig that
hasn't happened for me yet I would like
to not be irritated by her that's that's
kind of my only request right now hell
Ben yes if yes if I ever redid my 10
worst episodes of new who yes hell-bent
would absolutely be on there was torture
what good should i watch it I don't know
how to answer that
Torchwood could be good aside from
children of Earth which was effectively
the third series
it was never consistently good so I
approached Torchwood with caution
runaway bride or Iraq ins in the UK I
would I would watch runaway bride before
I would rewire a cannons in the
okay because they much as there's a lot
of stuff and we run and run away bride
that I don't like there is at least some
stuff that I do I really got nothing for
reckons in the UK do you like that they
first introduced the Dalek into the new
who era yo you mean like back in
Eccleston's run yeah yeah that was
really well done that was a doubly great
episode may the name dr. Donna live
forever
will you ever visit the UK again I have
no idea I would love to I have no plans
to I can't afford to but I would love to
I would love to visit the UK yeah but I
have absolutely no plans to do so as of
right now
have you seen Star Trek the original
series bits and pieces when I was a kid
I kind of grew up on next generation so
I had a really hard time getting over
the production values of the original
which was also part of why I couldn't
get into Doctor Who when I was younger
cuz like I had a friend who was you know
I had a PBS household so I did see I
think it was a part of a fifth doctor or
something or other at some point and
couldn't get into it because of how
wonky the effects were um so like I
could probably appreciate original Trek
better now but I just I don't know I
don't feel a pull to do that
what arachnids in the UK be on your 10
where I don't know man you seem to want
me to like spontaneously generate a 10
worst for you over the course of
livestream I'm not gonna do it
I don't know
are there any companions you want to
come back and Jody's run um I think
bringing back Captain Jack will be good
I have mixed feelings about the idea of
bringing river back because I'm kind of
I feel like we needed to be done with
River but at the same time I do enjoy
her and I kind of would like to see her
bounce off of Whitaker
and I suppose the other one that oh god
I had it and I lost it no it's gone that
there was one that that occurred to me
like to to bring back but and it wasn't
like one of the main companions now I've
lost it if I'm lucky within the next how
much time we got a couple of minutes
it'll come to me and I'll just end up
shouting it out
what about Martha I look Martha is a
kind of a shortchanged companion she
deserved better than she got but I don't
given that I didn't especially love the
times that they did bring her back
already I kind of am not overly eager
for them to do it again
Oh ace okay yeah if you're going back to
classic Harry yes please bring back ace
absolutely do that do you think
directives in the UK was a mono remake
of the green death and what classic
story would you like to see modernised I
haven't seen the green death so I
couldn't tell you from what I understand
of it and maybe and I don't maybe cause
of axis because that was some cool ideas
with some really wonky effects that that
that might be something worth revisiting
do you think Jody's doctor suffers from
being too team-oriented
um a little bit there's just too many
people in the TARDIS right now so we
haven't really gotten to know any of
them particularly well oh I just
remember what it was I would like to see
Whitaker encounter not rose but the bad
wolf entity that Billie Piper play I
don't know how you justify it I don't
care how you justify it I would like to
see that I really liked Billie Piper as
so
the bad wolf entity I loved that a lot
and that dad I would like to see brought
back in some fashion ah would you like
Amy or Bill more well the thing is both
of them had pretty definitive sign offs
so I just worry that however you would
have to bring them back would cheapen
them between the two I would say bill
cuz I was left you know I didn't get
enough of Bill for my taste but that's
me um I'm nervous for your da legs in
Manhattan review because I really like
it oh boy you have good reason to be
nervous let's just go with that a bit of
a weird question do you think the doctor
could ever be a teenager do you think it
could be good ah no and it's because I
don't have faith that they could find a
teenage actor to bring the the vibe in
the feel and the sense of age to the
part I'm not saying that no such actor
exists but I don't trust them to find it
so like it's Hien age doctors the kind
of thing that like if they ever wanted
to explore like I don't know in the
comics in a novel like have something
like the war doctor it was a you know a
regeneration that we didn't really get
it in the show very much or at all if
they wanted to do that there that's fine
but for the show I just don't think that
you'd get somebody who could who could
sell it I mean it's not impossible but I
wouldn't have faith in that okay I think
I do need to wrap it up it's been about
an hour and I should attempt to eat some
dinner see how well that goes what about
number five from Umbrella Academy is the
doctor okay interesting pick I I don't
believe he
is from the UK I believe he is American
and I do have a hard no Americans rule
but you know he's he does pretty well
with that vibe I still worry about
centering you know centering a whole
series around him knowing what the
doctor can be and has been in the past I
just I just think it's a it's something
that's gonna even if it's good it's
going to feel very very gimmicky in a
way that I don't think the gender swap
or doing a non-white race or anything
like that actually would be and that is
it i I am done so thank you all for
tuning in and and yeah sure thing do I
have anything else to say
I really don't so thanks for watching
thanks for listening thanks for viewing
thanks for talking
i I do enjoy this and I'm really glad
that I've been able to keep it up next
week's will be 9 p.m. I'm not gonna
switch it on you next time because next
week is the one that was always supposed
to be 9 p.m. it's later on down the line
that the schedule gets thrown off but
we'll deal with that when we get there
so um that'll be it for tonight folks so
I hope everybody has